hé,
où es-tu allé, écureuil
[Musique]
par terre,
chut
quand Sire nous emmène dans le nouveau monde,
je n'ai pas besoin de noms,
je veux dire huit neuf q un deux, ce n'est pas
vraiment un nom
donc
j'aimerais que mon nom soit
Lila
[Musique  ]
c'est un joli nom Lila
merci
je pense que mon nom sera Voleurs
parce que même si nous les avons tous, les
miens sont certainement les voleurs les plus en vue de l'
équipe Lila me donne un conseil
parce que le sol parce que moi est allongé sur
le sol tu es allongé sur le sol alors  ton
nom est floor ouais
oh
non et
ton ami
un jour je vais fabriquer de superbes machines
qui volent
et moi et mes amis allons
voler ensemble
dans le ciel magnifique et éternel Lila
conseils
et floor
et moi fusée fusée
c'est vraiment bien de  avoir des amis